what a season it's been here are my top
moments don't forget to subscribe to
keep getting clips and thanks for
watching well were you shot where but in
front of my grandmother's house but
we're in a party cuz I get you the
doctor's office it is okay but most of
them in the legs I get hit my hand and
they hit in the face
so like the fragment portion of it is in
my tongue so it kind of changed would I
speak a little bit like and you're
rapping as well yeah what is it still in
your tongue
can you see yeah it's great for oral sex
let me just make a note of that
you rigged the songs I mean the artists
sing and their big anthems all of them
so could you ever tour an album
yeah you just do it you do it down
actually Adele gave me top tip she was
like yeah whenever you can't hit the
high note you just like you're like
lalala Brooklyn put this picture up on
Instagram and he put on it rockin the
old school Ralph Lauren look at that
he's got three hundred seventeen
thousand likes okay so that you know
cool in his Ralph Lauren they scroll
through the comments you know oh yeah
whatever blood one of the blur blur blur
get down to this one mr. David Beckham
that's my jumper
he happens on this program honestly we I
could feel it this is him it's a little
video he posted on Instagram to reboost
about the number of his followers here
we go
so it's my mom's birthday today okay
I just reached a million followers I've
got 52 I have trouble remembering lyrics
just in general I remember jams I
remember the tunes but do you remember
the one would that you did that goes
like it's just you singing and piano
yeah Hannah ha yeah Joe please ah don't
make your kids really jealous what's
that is if you just posed with a
lightsaber with thin that would actually
make them very gently do it you've got
on David Beckham you've got
your match I just wanted to meet you me
then Benedict became famous one of the
first things that happened was his fat
like this is so random that his vana
decided that he looked very like an
otter are you aware of this
I'm sorry this is an opportunity for
myself and Johnny to channel our inner
otter this is a nice three shot
if you lean in are leaning yeah exactly
okay lean it to me oh you're in the
middle in a way what's the face any
other okay there was no moment when you
got a new the Voldemort look was working
when you were on set I knew you met yeah
I passed by the script supervisor has a
little boy he was on set I mean his son
may be her son I think it for five years
old
anyway I passed by this little child I
just looked at this boy he is burst into
tears
but it's it's just there's something I
don't know something about it makes me
want to kind of do
don't keep them there they go to Kyoto
but putting the pork under the table
explain that to them well this idea of
that could put like a fork under the
table to see if anybody notices it all
these little things but they don't drop
the four don't know that place it under
this and you don't notice I let's see if
you see yet to see if they'll notice oh
there's a missing fork where is it Wow
don't try that at Nando's I'm asking now
we've all done and those Nando's bro
you don't help America you'd love it
though you would like with it yes it's
like chicken I'm not a chicken chicken
place you've done several wedding I love
that back again on their poster Sienna
Miller it's like chicken so you the
famous quiz episode when the girls lose
the apartment yes I remember okay yeah
so uh what the guys wanted you to see if
you could remember the answers to the
Chandler questions in the quiz if you
can't Gemma artisans right on it do you
remember this episode no Miriam no hope
so it only don't shout out till magic
don't get it but feel free to shout out
if you could not get it no pressure is
on okay here we go here we go according
to Chandler what phenomenon scares the
bejesus out of them oh that's Michael
Flatley lord of the dance you are
correct
yes welcome okay countless elevator
rides I'll be in the elevator in a in a
mother and child will get on and the
mother will say it's woody
kids go then the mother tries to explain
Oh their voice is recorded and the actor
who is the voice this is the actor the
kids just don't get it at all I said
where's the vest where's the cowboy hat
you're not very tall and so I say hmm
all right close your eyes like a lot
just just close your eyes so they can go
and then we got to get back to Andy's
room right away guys and what is the
name of Chandler's father's all-male
burlesque
I actually know that - that's Viva Las
Vegas
but was it Jaguar and you - right a
horse
are you a natural Horseman and I think
I'm more naturally a horse than a horse
what hello
okay every week the TV Guide comes to
Chandler and Joey's apartment
what name appears on the address label
mrs. Chandler bong
you know Kelly were kind of looking for
love yeah and then we notice Justin
Bieber was sitting two rows behind us
and we thought you know what Valentine's
Day is coming up we're both single let's
just make a play for him like a first we
thought it would be funny but then it
actually worked and we sent Justin a
note through our bodyguard I think we've
got the note all right so dear Justin my
name is Kelly Osbourne and my name is
rebel Wilson we think you should take
our sexy hot asses out after oh nothing
weird yeah you can see from exhibit a it
is ticked seven times yes
we hung out all night oh do you yeah cuz
I think most girls meet Justin and be
like ah and be a bit pathetic but like I
mean him it just was like hey what's up
the game yeah I was a partner what's it
looks quite nervous even oh no that's
just cuz I was holding his balls the
night I won my I don't want to talk
about that night I had a whole meltdown
um okay I was reading it was like birth
control confusion so I was like hormonal
I fell on my face I forgot to thank the
director so I was just like what does it
all mean nothing
I just like I came home crying then my
friend was like ordered the wrong pizza
I was in thin crust it was thick crust I
was like you created the breeze right so
how do you how do you do it what it's a
six part process uh-huh that starts
really first of all with the thought the
inception of it and secondly it's
starting to feel it in the lower part of
your body and then allowing it to come
up and then really pushing through from
the diaphragm up through the throat and
then out through the nose
mm-hmm without thinking at all you just
have to clear your mind that's probably
the biggest thing and he said a powder
is it up a jaw it's it's a combination
of it's really a it's this is more it's
more it's not even the the result like
what what you're doing with your face is
what you're thinking okay which is just
like okay take it already I'm getting
your kids they aspire to be a performer
like you oh yeah I'm I'm in trouble
my my kids are just like me take the cut
it's scary
associate not my son my son is a little
slower my daughter is just okay it's my
son I catch nothing
I catch my son doing some of the stupid
stuff why are you looking that wall
I'm just playing no you're not playing
licking the wall Daisy you got to use
your lovely English voice I do
throughout I do it John
not so much no I have an American accent
do it he's so good oh it's in credit
your accent is so good
oh thank you I mean I tried it in the
British but it didn't work out I'm a
stormtrooper man I ever say yeah I'll
say yes yes I'm Jake you're just like uh
John I don't think it's right let's go
with America but what if you hadn't been
able to do America then I would have
been pierced you did the voiceovers for
some of the trailers you did yeah I did
yeah what's a good night yeah yeah
exactly yeah I love that stuff too I do
it at home all the time pres my wife
nuts it's them you know it's that voice
that in world / fear one man must stand
alone
Will Smith Ryan Reynolds Catherine
zeta-jones
Tobey Joe Graham Norton's pants rated on
redick Cumberbatch wherever you go you
have very ardent fans orgrim he said I
do
oh dude by the medium of gin and tonic I
said I do yes and somebody saw a
Benedict on location in Boston and we've
got a picture of you on set that day and
so she she saw Benedict and immediately
rushed home and went on to Reddit and
she goes um I saw a Boston batch cuz
that's your name in Boston it's an
adaptable saying yes I saw boss about
this morning bury me in a y-shaped
coffin for I am dead so it's right
[ __ ] he is fine he was wearing a blue
hat a dark blue polish on the gray pants
and the white shoes he's taller than I
thought I suspected who's about 511 want
to be six-foot of an object's foot tall
and ripped like her really much more
muscly than I was expecting those arms
dad ass and the arm veins were in full
effect popping there's not an ounce of
fat on that man it's all muscle
sinuan wholesome goodness and the hat
looks better in real life too but the
last leg with the Hat forgot the last
paragraph as though were you just I
think whoa I couldn't smell him I really
tried
and he was so close that had he been
wearing cologne I think I would have
been able to tell just the lightest
cumber musk in the box I was growing my
mustache out for anchorman 2 and
coaching on the sidelines and the
opposing coach was like you look
familiar
and I go yeah are you that actor I'm
like I think so he said is that mustache
real said yes why would I be wearing a
fake kids it's happened honey hold on I
got to put my fake book so that I'm
unrecognizable no but I feel though
Colin sometimes I feel too great you
felt a little woozy you fight your
beauty and you often use the medium of
hair to fight you I have some of the
worst hairdos in film do really yeah no
genuine like a vampire magazine did top
10 worst hairdos and film I'm definitely
three of those intentional like Horrible
Bosses is intentional and that's wasn't
one of the three I was talking dude what
a movie I love home at the end of the
world
oh thanks it's just such a good movie
and you're so good in it however that's
having hampered like I mean that's a
testament they oughta mess I was at the
time that I actually stood in front of a
camera without a maker
I believe I've gone to dinner with her
do that thing where some people make a
list of people famous people that they
had allowed to have sex with if they
meet them the free pass the free pass
right yeah she called an allowance and I
was like wow that pocket money yeah
how are you good to spend me and so met
her and her fella and and then she came
up and said after a sprint
so you're my allowance and I was like I
beg you excuse me
index rent you you know he's cool with
it and you're my thing and I was like by
the way that's a whole other story and
and I was really sort of like taken
aback right and and was I'm married and
thank you very much for the really nice
union and she said this thing it was
like it was meant as a compliment and
she was trying to get me to do stuff but
it was still really backhanded and she
went kiss you know a lot of girls would
be after somebody like Channing Tatum
Jane Eyre you had a horse oh yeah you
had a very bad behavior on Jane Eyre
yeah Prince and was the horse yeah so
what would happen well he used to get
quite aroused when whenever I got in his
back
oh yeah good yeah understand me about
you didn't i guessing you don't
sugarcoat things you get starstruck when
you meet Michael I do sometimes I do
sometimes I remember when I was young I
and I met Laurence Olivier well that was
I used to collect autographs at the
stage door and he came out and I
remember so distinctly that I started to
cream in my knickers wherever we thought
that story was going
I honestly don't think I've ever been
more uncomfortable
I think that's the worst moment of my
life
oh well that's a lovely story mirror
thank you for sharing I think that's in
the compilation that's that's great
I want to say I like a silly Scott he
just turns to me and he goes Jonah Jonah
Bobo no banana fanna fo Fona me